hey 42 here millenials stereotypically
known for their avocados blended
breakfast oat milk meditation Pilates
yoga and random bouts of veganism
ostensibly they appear to be Paragons of
health and wellness there's a
self-confidence amongst millennial
culture that the way they are living is
the optimum way to do so and they would
fully expect to stay healthier for
longer into old age than their parents
or grandparents but now millions of
Millennials around the world are
beginning to reach there early to late
thirties a time when age-related issues
can start to appear so the first time we
can finally start to measure the early
results of this large-scale millennial
wellness experiment to see if it is
showing signs of paying off
however worryingly new research has
indicated that perhaps it hasn't and
that Millennials may in fact be the
least healthy generation of the past 100
years could it be the case that their
parents and grandparents have lived
healthier and happier lives than they
will let's find out but first a quick
word from today's sponsor raid shadow
legends have you already played raid
shudder legends if not then right now is
the time to start because it's finally
available for PC and Mac raid on PC has
the same great core gameplay as the
Android and iOS versions but with a ton
of extra graphical goodies seriously
guys it's amazing especially the
graphics you have to check them out but
don't worry you don't need a super
powerful processor or badass gamers
computer to enjoy the game at speed and
with amazing graphics it runs super
smoothly and the install barely took me
a few minutes
it's a cross-platform game so you can
install the game on your PC or Mac and
then continue playing on your mobile
device also so basically you can play
raid anywhere there are over 400
champions to collect and customize so my
favorite champion is probably the
beefy guy because it looks like Sunter
with a sword and he can freeze his
enemies which is super fun to play
around with I'm absolutely loving it so
far and I know you will too oh and best
of all this game is free to download and
play you can start playing right now by
hitting the link in the description make
sure to use my link because you'll get
50,000 free silver under free epic
champion as part of the new player
program lion game nickname is 40 and you
can come join my clan today now when I
refer to Millennials earlier I chose the
phrasing millennial culture
intentionally whilst technically
Millennials are anyone born between 1982
and 2002 I don't think it right to
classify all these billions of young
people as Millennials Millennials have
carved out their own monotone herd-like
culture that is so easily defined it
would be unfair and incorrect to say
that every young person is a millennial
thankfully not every modern youth
worships overpriced monitor stands
spends their days on Instagram and burns
any cookbook that includes words such as
steak or tasty for regular people whose
daily wellness routine consists of
sniffing the milk to check it won't make
you vomit if you pour it all over your
cheerios some of the things Millennials
do to ostensibly improve their health
can seem utterly bizarre they drink
charcoal but turmeric in their lattes
and now they're beginning to eat insects
and inject themselves with IVs yes both
of those are now millennial health fads
that are about to explode
Millennials are increasingly buying
cookies and other snacks who have
ground-up crickets in them and also
baking with cricket flour and yes there
is also a growing trend to get a regular
vitamin IV drops not when you're on well
just because why the hell not a 2019
study conducted by Blue Cross Blue
Shield's a Federation of 36 US health
insurance
companies found that insects and
avocados may be doing Millennials a lot
more harm than good
the study found that across-the-board
Millennials consistently score worse for
all types of health issues psychological
unphysical than the previous generation
the previous generation being Gen X
those born between the 1960s and
eighties Millennials health stays at a
reasonably high level during their early
20s and is in line with but not
necessarily better than Gen Xers quality
of health between the ages of 20 to 26
so whatever Millennials are doing during
their early 20s isn't necessarily
helping them but it's not harming them
either however according to this
comprehensive study everything changes
once they hit 27 weirdly 27 seems to be
a cliff edge for Millennials where the
quality of that overall health plummets
into a mysterious abyss it would be
reasonable to assume that this decline
in health is simply due to aging but
millennial health seems to worsen so
severely after 27 that the drop far
exceeds what any doctor would attribute
to normal aging and their health drops
off significantly more so than it did
for Generation X or baby boomers once
they reach 27 there's something more
going on here something to do with the
unique lifestyle and Millennials lead
which the previous generations didn't
let's drill down into these worrying
statistics a little further this table
shows the ten most prevalent health
conditions affecting Millennials today
between the ages of 21 and 36 in 2014
major depression affected just under
four percent of Millennials
unfortunately this isn't surprising we
have known for some time now that with
young people we are today facing the
worst epidemic of depression and mental
health issues in modern history between
2013 and 2016 diagnosis of depression
amongst Millennials
rose by a staggering 47% but what's
interesting is that during the same
period depression diagnosis rose by 33
percent across the rest of the
population - for me this just further
qualifies the widely held suspicion that
this increase is at least somewhat
linked to social media because the
entire population is increasingly using
it but Millennials and the younger
generations have integrated it the most
into their lives looking again at these
results what is most alarming is a huge
increase in diagnosis across the board
in Millennials as they age as you can
see after aging just three years this
same group of people saw a 31% increase
in major depression 29 percent increase
in hyperactivity and 22 percent increase
in type 2 diabetes and this is something
that has changed with time it's not
saying that globally these issues are
affecting people more in 2017 than they
were in 2014 this study followed people
who were born during a specific year
range so these are for statistics sake
the very same people just three years
older indicating a worrying health
decline as Millennials age but all this
means nothing without a control groups
who measure against so let's take a look
at how Millennials stack up against the
preceding generation the Gen Xers this
chart shows the prevalence per 100
people of the same health issues of Gen
Xers aged 34 to 36 and Millennials aged
34 to 36 the difference in years of the
source data is so that both generations
could be analyzed when they were both
the very same age as ages the most
critical factor to quality of health as
you can see for every condition except
alcohol use disorder and psychotic
conditions millenials showed much higher
prevalence across the board than there
others reaching as much as a 37%
increase in prevalence for hyperactivity
what's interesting to me is that there
is actually just a free year age gap
between both these groups the Gen Xers
here were born just three years before
the Millennials yet the health
differences are so stark which indicates
that during the switchover when the
world began producing millennials
something drastically changed which
meant that Millennials were brought up
in a very different cultural
technological and social environments
than those only three years earlier one
of the most alarming statistics for me
as can be seen here is that at the very
same age Millennials are 21% more likely
to suffer from cardiovascular conditions
than Gen Xers that's a large increase in
a very dangerous physical health
condition there's also a growing
disparity between young men and young
women the women have always been
diagnosed with depression endocrine and
fibroid issues at much higher rates than
men but amongst young people the gender
health gap is widening one recent study
from the CDC found that the rate of new
diagnoses of type 2 diabetes rose much
more sharply in females 6.2 percent than
in males 3.7 percent ages 10 to 19 this
is obviously looking at Generation Z not
Millennials but there is shockingly
almost double the increase in type 2
diabetes prevalence for young females
than males why well honestly the
researchers still haven't figured that
one out yet they're still looking into
what may be the cause and when it comes
to millennials BlueCross BlueShield
found that overall female millenials are
20% less healthy than their male
counterparts there's an important
question to be answered here why is this
happening why is millennial health so
much worse than Generation X and baby
boomers and why does their health
decline so dramatically when they hit 27
well there are two facets of health to
discuss here psychological and physical
let's first discuss the psychological as
we have discussed depression amongst
Millennials is as a record-high also
they are dying from alcohol and drug
overdoses at a higher rate than any
previous generation psychologists
believe there are two primary factors
driving this dark trend the first is
money stress statistically you are three
times more likely to have a mental
health disorder if you have unsecured
debt and unfortunately Millennials have
more debt than any of a generation
the average millennial has $28,000 of
debt excluding mortgages at the same age
Gen Xers had on average $13,000 a debt
less than half and though this is not
because of student loans in fact student
loans contribute a small amount to this
average the largest contributor to this
debt is credit card bills accounting for
an average of 25% of this 28k debt and I
don't need to tell you that that's a
fairly unhealthy type of debt yes some
Millennials have done very very well for
themselves the Zuckerberg tech startup
crowd are generating immense amounts of
new money but those are a tiny fraction
of Millennials less than one in a
million it's usually not their fault but
the vast majority of Millennials are
living in a gig economy according to Pew
Research two-thirds of Millennials live
paycheck to paycheck and only 38% feel
financially stable the reason behind
this is a mix of a changing world and a
faster more harsh economy that can seem
harder to crack than in the past for
those who are just starting out in their
careers but also Millennials grew up
with role models such as Zuckerberg Elon
Musk and others who started their
billion-dollar companies from their
bedrooms this has instilled the
mentality amongst Millennials that every
young person can become filthy rich just
by creating an app
starting a new social network the
reality is that these are
one-in-a-billion rare occurrences that
require a touch of genius mixed with a
heap of look millennial expectations are
well above the reality of the world that
they live in which has always required
still requires and probably always will
require endless graft with little phrase
just to put food on the table and today
you can still get ahead of everyone else
and secure a well-paid job but it
requires just as much savvy Sun which
can sometimes come as a surprise to an
Instagram generation who I used to the
fake personas they see on social media
every day of a few people in Los Angeles
who roll out of bed every morning into a
pool of money because they invented a
vegan milkshake that makes you [ __ ] ten
pounds a week and that brings me nicely
unto the next reason for declining
millennial Mental Health social media
now I've talked about this extensively
before so I'll be brief the fear of
missing gowns that Millennials
experience on a daily basis from
browsing social media and the idea that
someone out there is always leading a
better life than themselves has created
a damaging culture of unfulfilled youth
that always want and expect more from
their own life but may never get it
Instagram and other apps have
indoctrinated us into a false idea of a
lifestyle where every meal looks
picture-perfect and we never work we
simply spend our day strolling through
forests surfing the waves in Miami or
taking selfies on top of a Norwegian
mountain of course this is all a show
and it's fake a fraud even the people
who regularly post that content do not
live like that I promise you from Prince
to pauper everyone's lives are
reassuringly dull because Instagram and
Facebook only shows everyone highlights
but beneath the Sharada there are always
lows even if you
a celebrity or a billionaire in fact
often even more of them unfortunately
though many Millennials have a tough
time understanding why their own life
doesn't live up to this manufactured
Instagram lifestyle that they soak in
every day and so will always feel empty
and unfulfilled the mental health
consequences of this attitude are
disastrous and ultimately lead to
depression but what could be causing the
steep decline in the physical health of
Millennials surely we can't blame
increased diabetes and heart disease
prevalence on social media - well we
probably could if we tried hard enough
but no in all seriousness researchers
believe it's another millennial trend
driving this physical health decline
Millennials cook much less often than
previous generations on average
Millennials cook to fewer evening meals
per week than baby boomers they also
choose ready meals 20% of the time
compared to just 5% for baby boomers
also Millennials by far fewer groceries
and boomers and Gen Xers and they eat
out a lot more or increasingly get
deliveries from companies such as
delivery and uber eats ready meals
deliveries and eating out are just
nowhere near as healthy and nutritious
as home-cooked meals that's just a fact
unless your average midweek home-cooked
meal consists of deep fried lard
Millennials also eat much more junk food
and processed food than the previous
generations add on the fact that
technology means young people are
staying in more than ever before in
history we're socializing nowhere near
as much as we used to know social media
is not socializing and are thus getting
less exercise all this together means
that Millennials are now the most obese
generation in history based on current
projections 70% of Millennials will be
overweight or obese
by the time they hit their 30s compared
to 50% of baby boomers when they were
the same age and so this would at least
partially explain the huge increase in
physical health conditions when
Millennials reached early 20s usually
beginning at 27 because that's when the
metabolism starts to slow down and so
their bad eating habits catch up with
them and the weight certainly piles on
the eating habits of young people have
changed more so over the past decade
than ever before in the previous 50
years we are coming to the end of an
experiment that will ultimately
determine whether hundreds of fad diets
food trends and food group exclusions
can really be healthier than the
time-tested traditional food archetype
of meat veg and potatoes or some
variants we are only at the beginning of
seeing the results of this global
experiment and so far those results are
less than promising so let us see what
the following decades bring thank you
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then be sure to subscribe and don't
forget to check out the sponsor Rach
other legends by using my unique link in
the video description